the great thing about being an actor is
they you're invited into people's worlds
that you normally would never be invited
into people want to tell their stories
they want to be seen and they want to be
understood as an actor you just get to
go on these incredible journeys that
most people are never invited to or
never have an opportunity to to travel
on 13 going on 30 the character I played
in 13 going on 30 is Matt flam half who
was a plucky awkward kid who grew up to
be a photographer he fell in love with
his childhood sweetheart played by
Jennifer Garner Gary Winnick rest in
peace we came up in in the kind of the
indie New York theater and film scene he
got this chance to do a big-budget film
and it was 13 going on 30 and he's like
hey man I want to do this romantic
comedy but I don't want to do it like
all these other things I want to have a
message and he gave me a script but it
wasn't great and we all worked on it to
try and make it into something that that
we felt would be worthy of our time and
we shot and came out really really nice
I didn't know it was gonna become iconic
I did know that the message isn't it
were real you know we played it all as
real as we could and I and I think it's
a in a weird way a really wholesome
movie for for young women you know and
young men Turner Sunshine of the
spotless mind Michel Gondry was this
amazing director that everyone wanted to
work with I heard about that he was
doing a movie and I asked for the script
and they told me there's you know it's
just a kind of a small part in it and I
read it and I was like yeah it is a
small part but I just think I could do
something kind of fun and cool with this
but I'd like to talk to him so I I had a
meeting with Michelle and I was like you
know so I see this guy he's like you
know he sits in his room by himself
playing the bass and his underwear you
know like I I see him with like a
pompadour he's like a pompadour I was
like
like my kind of like that but like a
mohawk like half mohawk you know he's
really into the clash and none of that
was in the script really you know Michel
was like I love these men these sounds
gorgeous man and he cast me it was an
amazing experience and we improvised so
much of that movie and we were writing
it on the fly they came to us they're
like you're shooting 36,000 feet of film
a day we had like four cameras rolling
non-stop and focus actually came in and
like shot us down they're like you can't
you can't shoot this much but the camera
would be rolling well we were just
sitting there bolting around and then
Michelle loved that he was he used a lot
of that stuff in there Kirsten Dunst is
this great scene and most dancing in her
underwear you know what Jim Carrey's
body lay and that was totally improvised
came out of us like passing a drawing
around and like really feeling a feeling
that feeling you know and then and then
it just broke out in this spontaneous
stupid you know dancing to this day like
a really sweet sweet movie moment zodiac
sometimes you're making characters up
and sometimes you're playing real people
and then that I played Dave toski who I
you know I was fortunate was still alive
you're reading a script and you get one
idea of a person you know he's good he's
like this hard-boiled you know San
Francisco murder cop and I'm gonna play
him tough and then I said well I'd love
to meet Dave toski you know everyone was
freaked out like you really want to meet
him I was like yeah I don't want to I
want to go hang out with him so took a
commuter flight to San Francisco and I
went and met him he was working in a
little security firm I wouldn't spend a
day with them I spent a few days of film
in San Francisco I found that when
you're playing all the people the best
thing to do is to get them drunk or a
little bit drunk
cuz the Neffs when they really like open
up to you but you have to put yourself
on the line too so you have to tell some
embarrassing stories about yourself
first but after a while you know he won
my trust me already
looked at me like who's this Hollywood
kid you know what is he doing here I
really like created a nice rapport with
him and really realized that my idea my
Hollywood idea of him was so far off
from from the truth you know and who he
was and and and the idiosyncratic
aspects of the way he talked the way he
dressed even done like eating the animal
crackers were so much more interesting
and than anything that I could have come
up with David Fincher who is like my
hero and we had the most just incredible
kind of collaboration on that he's still
one of my close friends you know we were
all in my in my trailer one like a
Friday night drinking and Fincher who
never really liked carouses with the
with the crew and the you know he keeps
a really strong border between
fraternizing I poked my head out of my
trailer and he was standing out there
with an empty glass and he was like
smoking a cigarette like probably like
his tenth cigarette in his life and I
was like David he's like yeah oh hey I
was like you want to come in cuz I'd
always invite him to come by he's like
oh are you are you guys there and I was
like yeah come on up and he's like oh I
guess I will then you know and he came
in and I poured him a big shot of
bourbon and we were sitting there after
a while it was just him and I I was like
how's it going he's like I don't know
and I said what do you mean and he's
like I I don't know if they're gonna
kill me or not I don't know if this is
working to have that kind of a moment
with that kind of director and that kind
of vulnerability is also another gift of
being in this business shutter island'
we had rehearsals and Marty was like
okay these are the films I want you to
see I have a screening room and we're
gonna watch these movies together
and I'm sitting there it's me and Marty
and Leo we're watching out of the past
and I turned to Marty and I'm like Marty
what if my character because he's
playing this this other character that's
not him what if he like went and watched
all these Robert Mitchum movies and he's
like doing a Robert Mitchum imitation
because he he's he sees it as like the
hard-boiled detective that he thinks he
should be and he's like yeah yeah I mean
I I get do whatever you want kid well
look at it we'll see what how it works
and and so yeah I did that and that
whole character came out of that out of
the past screening Leo and I went
through like this crazy journey it was
six months in rain we were wet the whole
time we had wet suits on underneath our
clothes and I just remember like going
to his trailer and playing xbox totally
soaked shooting this you know 1930s
movie and we're in period costumes the
kids are all right my brother just
passed away just before that and I was
really disillusioned probably with my
own with my life but also like
filmmaking and I was like this is gonna
be my last movie as an actor it was an O
Maj to my brother the character my
brother was like this just incredibly
charismatic sexy dangerous beautiful fun
vivacious human being and so I'm like
I'm gonna play him in this movie it was
a great experience I felt free in a way
that I hadn't in a long long time
as an actor I remember I made peace at
the idea of quick of stopping acting and
transitioning it to more directing and
writing I was at Sundance with it and
I'll never forget I was sitting in the
audience the first time I'd ever seen it
and I heard the audience's response to
it which was so sincere and beautiful
and was addressing this moment and time
and culture where we're talking about
gay marriage and I saw like how
important
film could be how much people enjoyed it
and how much I actually enjoyed it
really deeply when I got outside the
business of Hollywood and just purely
like that the experience of making films
I was like okay I'm not I'm not going
anywhere and so I gave up the idea like
you know what are the box office is what
are the reviews what of what it you know
what all that is and just focused on
what I actually had control over and
what gave me joy
Annette Bening Julianne Moore the love
scenes are crazy you know triangle the
the humor you know is everything that I
loved about cinema and why I wanted to
do it and I just felt really free the
original Avengers totally was like I'm
the wrong guy you know this is this
world I don't know how to do this Josh
Whedon sat me down said no I think you
are the guy I said well I don't I can't
really sign on to doing something unless
I read a script I mean that's the only
power has an actor to be able to say no
to something I don't know what the hell
you're making he's like how what is if I
send you 20 pages I read the scene when
Black Widow comes to find banner
I read that scene and I knew the tone of
it but now we need you to come in what
if I say no I'll persuade you and what
if the other guy says no and then I got
a call from Robert Downey who's you know
my hero and he said come on Ruffalo we
got this and and that was it and I was
in I've done so much motion capture I
have to wear what I call the man
cancelling suit which is this really
tight leotard that makes you look big
where you want to look small and small
where you want to look big I miss it man
it was so humiliating and all the actors
whenever I'd walk on set would just
start laughing at me because they were
in their cool superhero costumes and I'm
wearing this ridiculous pajamas that
made me look like a Chinese checkerboard
there was even one point where I catch
Downey whole catches down he puts them
on the
ground right and I decide I'm gonna do
this Hulk roar over him in my little
leotard and he just kind of hands he has
his eyes closed and he opens one eye and
he's just like really Ruffalo that's
what you're going with
and that's what it's always been like
like in the last movie he came out to me
and he said I have a lot of compassion
for you
and I was like why is that cuz I see how
hard it is for you to stand around and
that costume all day Foxcatcher
that thing had been around for a long
time and I'd asked I kept asking to be
to be seen for it because I was a
wrestler and it was six months of
wrestling and working out and putting on
40 pounds really grueling and all the
rest when you see in there is also
wrestling and I had another real
character although he was he wasn't
alive but his family really opened
themselves to me I really got to know
Dave Schultz in in a you know post
posthumous way a great another great
experience Channing Tatum he's my bro
you know we went through that experience
together and yeah I'm really proud of
that movie like occasionally you get
movies that are just purely for
entertainment and you get movies that
that that are called forth from the
culture in society we're having a
conversation about an important issue
and spotlight was one of those things
that paid Mike Rezendes in another real
life character I spent weeks with him
again became really good friends with
them drank with him ate with him
absorbed myself into into that world of
the Washington Post at that particular
time and the people who were the victims
of of these priest molestation cases we
need the full scope that's the only
thing that will put an end to this now
let's take out the bed let him decide
we'll take it to Ben when I say it's
time it's time Robby it's time they knew
and they let it happen to kids okay
could have been you it could have been
me it could have been any of us and that
movie really sparked like change in the
world that's that's ongoing today the
moment where you're in service of
something that's important that need
that people need to know about and that
you can do in with cinema in a way you
can't do in any other form Darkwater
you know i'm an activist i've been an
activist probably since the iraq war it
was when i kind of really got into it i
began to see how powerful films were and
films could be in in that space in a way
that you can't really you can't do as an
activist you know because stories
transcend all the political and
ideological divides that immediately
come up when when you're when you're an
activist you know as time has gone on
I've wanted to blend more of my activism
with actual storytelling and this
article came up and I just saw it was a
place in the space that I've already
been working in which was water and this
incredible story about this lawyer who
was part of the system himself who was a
corporate defense attorney who was
completely indoctrinated in that culture
believed that corporations were people
that corporations could self-regulate
that the government shouldn't have
really much to do with that regulation
and he went through this experience that
he realized that that whole idea was a
fallacy and a lie they want to show the
world it's no use fighting look
everybody even he can't cracked amazing
he's helped build it
the system is rigged they want us to
think it'll protect us but that's a lie
we protect us we do I reached out to him
I talked to him his wife and I
immediately felt you know in love with
them and thought you know this has never
been done quite like this from this
point of view and he's so antithetical
to what a hero is to like the Hulk or
you know our other superheroes spoke
about a story that transcended all the
political ideology when we're so divided
right now I just felt like storytelling
is a way to unite people
these really big discussions that we had
to have in order to make our world a
better place and so that was my draw to
play Rob a lot and take control of you
know kind of what's what I'm doing going
forward
big part of choosing a role for me is
like does it challenge me is it does it
does it break me out does it does it
push me into the place that I never been
before that scares the [ __ ] out of me
you know as a story or a person that
expresses some dimension of my beliefs
or my feelings and lastly is it is it
something that can actually add to or
facilitate or even even bring forth a
conversation that needs to happen I
believe that the culture actually calls
the movie forward at a particular moment
in time when we're having a discussion
that is somehow encapsulated in that
project